brad and angelina's divorce battle is
coming up on five years and the case is
still far from settled
angelina even bringing up again her
accusation against brad
for domestic violence kev this is
getting nasty yeah it really is and we
have the exclusive new reporting on how
brad is responding to this
serious situation
you have challenges and you got some
uphills to face scary for a moment and
then you look at your options and you
make the best decision and you carry on
a source close to brad tells e.t he is
heartbroken
never attacked angie and is anxious to
get custody worked out so the family can
finally move on
we're also told those close to pitfield
jolie's recent domestic violence claim
is simply a ploy to sway the family
court in her favor
angie's endgame if jolie wins sole
custody
i think the worst case scenario would be
she then moves the kids away
and then brad would not be able to
regularly see them which would sever the
bond
i think of the joy that we have in our
family
because we are together the couple have
been locked in a bitter custody battle
since their split in 2016.
this is for my kids who color everything
i do i adore you
i love being a mommy i love my kids
earlier this month
the case took an ugly turn after new
court records revealed angie is claiming
she has proof of alleged domestic
violence against brad
and the kids could testify but et has
learned angie's filing was routine
and not a new allegation but one from
2016
where brad was cleared we reached out to
angie's rep for comment
our brad source also says it's worth
noting how much pitt's life has changed
since that 2016 incident
quote brad has acknowledged his past
drinking and taken responsibility for it
last year in a heartfelt speech he
thanked bradley cooper
i got sober because of this guy and
every day has been happier ever since i
love you and i thank you